and every moment come on now just put on
that purple wig one more time we can't
bear the thought that descendants 3 will
be the last movie we don't want to say
goodbye to you Evy Carlos J and the rest
of the characters so we hope you don't
mind if we reminisce a little while
longer
thankfully you have a gift for making us
laugh between takes on set it's no
secret that the cast of descendants
three had a huge amount of fun while
filming that's to be expected when you
work with your best friends we found of
Cameron's funniest season and three
onset moments that we can't wait to
share with you the last one on our list
had us laughing so hard wait until you
see what it is hard as we work we also
that's like fun time we get to be
creative and can you create such a safe
environment for us too butterfingers
Sophia Carson and dove Cameron are best
friends for a reason they have so much
in common including onset bloopers
remember when we showcase the Eevee's
lack of sword-catching skills and their
dissonance - behind the scenes video
well she's not the only one with
butterfingers watch mouth try to catch
the sword for the night Falls number she
misses it again and again and again
don't worry dove you can always fall
back on your other talents what's my
line even Disney superstars forget their
lines dove and the rest of the cast had
so much to remember they had to learn
how to sword fight they had to learn
dance choreography they had to learn the
songs and they had an entire script to
memorize that's a lot to fit into
anyone's brains so we weren't surprised
when Duff yelled
I'm so sorry what's my life during her
scene with Hades it makes us laugh
because nobody is perfect and we can so
relate to dove in this moment lazy
moments dove Cameron and China and
McClain gave us a lesson in being a good
person and not being lazy in this funny
behind-the-scenes video they are laying
on Audrey said while sophia carson is
filming her steam dove explains that as
an actor if you're off camera and you
don't act in the scene with other actors
was your bad person China's sleepily
says then dove says they are not doing
that today she adds that they are
leaving Sophia to fend for herself
I'm sure Sophia forgave them for having
a lazy moment when they were off-camera
goofy pictures and bad angles Disney
movie stars always look their best for
pictures right wrong we found some of
the goofiest behind-the-scenes pictures
with the absolute worst angles ever we
didn't know dub and Sophia could be so
silly
it makes us love them even more and this
doesn't even compare to dubs funniest
onset moment wait until you see what she
did in the makeup trailer with her
boyfriend Thomas Doherty at the end of
this video
tea time with dad we love these pictures
of dove Cameron and Cheyenne Jackson
behind the scenes on d3
it's hilarious that Hades would be
sitting down for a fancy tea with his
villain kid daughter hi dad he sticks
out like a sore thumb in that pretty
pink and gold room we love that they
took time to pose for these pictures
pinkies up guys fun with snapchat this
is so funny because it's a snapchat of
Dov taking a snapchat she is so adorable
with her own private mini photo shoot
turns out that it wasn't so private
after all we loved the antlers and
Wiggly ears seriously dub you would look
good with those moose antlers airplane
dove in the late Cameron voice were
super close friends in real life these
two were inseparable it's a real treat
when you get to work with your best
friends especially on set Dov and
Cameron always found fun and silly games
to play when they were in between takes
on set their cast mates snapped a
picture of these two plane airplane
Cameron is lifting dove into the air by
his feet while she balances overhead
such a fun moment night shoot things can
get a little crazy when you're up late
filming through the night dive captured
this funny moments in the middle of a
grueling night shoot they were coming
back from a coffee run Cameron Boyce is
next to dove looking totally delirious
that's what happens when you combine not
enough sleep with too much caffeine
we're glad they still manage to have a
good time
in the middle of the night trailer
musical theatre time dove Cameron Thomas
Doherty and Dylan Playfair are huge
musical theatre fans how do we know this
we found some behind-the-scenes videos
of them singing their hearts out two
seasons of love from rent and they
totally now their trailer renditions of
the Book of Mormon dove also filmed
Thomas and Dylan doing their best
version of the opening from The Lion
King these trailer musical theatre
moments are everything makeup chair
dancing and now it's time for our
absolute favorite hilarious dove Cameron
moment from her time on set for d3 she
and Thomas Doherty are doing this weird
quirky chair dance in the makeup trailer
and we can't stop laughing we're pretty
sure these two will be together forever
because they can completely dork out in
front of each other they have everyone
in the makeup trailer laughing
hysterically we hope this isn't what
their wedding dance will look like which
of daf Cameron's funny onset moments
made you laugh the most tell us in the
comments and while you're at it tell us
which villain kid is your all-time
favorite hit that subscribe button to be
the first to see our latest videos and
give us a big thumbs up if you liked
these on-set moments from d3 thanks for
watching the things catch you next time
[Music]